good morning believe nation today's
message is be yourself over to you
Whoopi Goldberg well my life is a class
if I was to say it probably teaches that
you can be yourself in an individual if
you are comfortable with not everybody
liking you or how you think if you're
comfortable with going against the grain
if you're comfortable with you know
people making fun or saying really nasty
stuff if you're comfortable with all
that you can be yourself
it's that surprise the price of being
yourself is you know other people's
angst about you being yourself I think
this is such an important message for
entrepreneurs because if you want to
have success as an entrepreneur in life
but especially as an entrepreneur if you
want to have success it has to come from
you being you from you being willing to
break the rules from you being willing
to express yourself from you being
willing to fail publicly and know that
even the fact that you are willing to
try and fail is an inspiration use it as
an inspiration not just to yourself but
to others around you and the people who
are watching you and judging you and
throwing tomatoes at you and seeing
you're not good enough and seeing that
was such a stupid mistake and laughing
at you you have to learn to ignore them
because if you just constantly live your
life according to other people's
judgments and expectations of you then
you're never going to have success
you're living up to somebody's
expectation who's never done what you
want to do your family or friends or
people in your community or saying that
you can't do this and you should be
doing this you should go down this path
instead of doing staying here and going
here you should be going down this path
according to them well have they done
what you want to do so you're living
your life according to what these
people's judgments are you're never
going to have success you're just going
to be a small
version of them and chances are they
haven't done much either so take the
little that they've done and be smaller
because that's not you congratulations
that's a happy life you can't just be a
copy of somebody you can't shave your
head we're a believ hoodie and come on
and do top ten videos and expect them to
do as well as mine
you can't outdo Evan Carmichael you
can't out Evan Evan just like I can't
out you you don't copy me go and do you
don't say yes because somebody wants you
to say yes because it's meant for you
the thing that I might disagree with
with Whoopi is that to get to the
comfort you need to go through
discomfort it's like saying don't be
afraid it's gonna work out don't be
afraid you're gonna be afraid it's okay
to be afraid it's okay to have fear
standing up to somebody it's okay to
have fear putting something out in the
public that you don't know is gonna work
or not it's okay to be afraid
it's not don't feel the fear it's feel
the fear and do it anyway it's feel that
fear that people are putting on you or
you're putting on yourself and this may
not work now this expression of myself
I'm pouring my heart out here and people
may not accept it and people may laugh
at it people say that it it's stupid and
then it will never work
pouring it out there anyway because you
know that it has to be released because
you need to know here's a quick personal
example when I first started doing these
videos here I did it at Toronto they and
salsa and we're in a mall and there's
people walking by constantly and there's
people who look in every now and then
and see what's happening in here what's
this guy doing in the day in studio with
lights and a book behind I'm talking and
yelling into a camera what's he doing
and at the start that was something that
I was sensitive about and in between
it's even worse like in between the
clips I have my head and my headphones
on and I'm dancing I'm doing this I'm
walking around the studio doing this to
see there's somebody watching right now
uh-huh that's how I this is this is what
I'm doing walk into the studio dancing
think of what I'm going to say next and
people are walking by
and I would let that hold me back I
would let their judgments make me play
small so instead of doing I dancing than
doing this a little bit smaller why am i
letting myself play smaller because of
some stranger's expectations of me why
are you letting yourself play smaller
because of strangers expectations of you
you will only have success by being you
by letting the thing that is different
about you come through and at the start
since your nurturing it since you're
starting it off it's the start of
anything you're gonna suck at it it's
not gonna be the best expression it's
not gonna have a fantastic result
chances are and so don't expect it
expect it to fail at the start that's
okay
you keep going if you keep practicing I
promise you you'll get to the point
where it's comfortable where you don't
care where you can let go of their
expectations just like working out your
muscles will get stronger but when you
first start doing it you need to
recognize that it's going to be scary
that it's going to be uncomfortable and
it's through that obstacle it's through
the discomfort that you get the comfort
comfort is on the other side of the
discomfort the answer isn't Crouchback
and be a small version of yourself
because if you stay here you're always
going to stay here your whole life and
you have to break through to get to what
you can so the question today today is
I'm curious what was the biggest thing
that you had to break through the
biggest discomfort that you had to break
through to be yourself
leave incomes below I'm gonna join in
the discussion I also want to give a
quick shout-out to Vamsi Polly metla
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word it really
really really really means a lot to me
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot event special
I spray so give me go